cada 23 de abril se celebra en todo el
mundo el día del libro una fecha que así
se estableció porque coincide con el día
del fallecimiento o más bien del funeral
del escritor español miguel de cervantes
se cree que el escritor de don quijote
de la mancha' nació en esta casa que
tengo a mis espaldas en la localidad
madrileña de alcalá de henares y hasta
aquí nos hemos desplazado para
preguntarle a los ciudadanos cuál es la
importancia para ellos de los libros y
de la lectura con los libros se viaja se
llora se ríe se sienten muchísimas
emociones
aprendes nuevo vocabulario y también
puedes soñar un montón con hasta un
pequeño
un pequeño texto puedes imaginarte un
montón de cosas y la verdad me encanta
leer tras dos años de ausencia por la
pandemia de kobe 19 la feria del libro
vuelve a la plaza principal de esta
ciudad que fue incluida en la lista de
patrimonio de la humanidad de la unesco
en 1998 una feria que da la posibilidad
de que lectores y escritores se vean las
caras e intercambien ideas eso es un
estímulo tanto para el escritor como
para el lector porque el escritor ve que
no está tan distante de la persona que
le va a interpretar tus textos
fomenta el poder comentar luego lo que
lees con los escritores y no es sólo una
firma muchas veces pues también comentar
lo que te ha parecido el libro pero para
nosotros estos eventos son esenciales
son primordiales para dar a difundir
nuestra obra y darnos a conocer al gran
público también desconocido como
nosotros lo somos una celebración del
arte escrito para fomentar la lectura y
el conocimiento puesto que como bien
dijo don quijote de la mancha' quien lee
mucho y anda mucho ve mucho y sabe mucho